you see the fire stand up like stop
grunting oh that's you right in front of
me Jesus you're pointing in the wrong
direction ha ha ha
oh I see it okay now crouch okay I'm
gonna stay to the right you stay -
laughing what if we end up killing this
dude this is gonna be the greatest thing
I've ever accomplished in the video game
the greatest thing really I don't have a
lot of video game accomplishments I have
to say with the Fargo it went out close
the door
someone in here yeah he's in there just
close the door see him moving around
he's standing in the middle yeah he just
opened the door he's looking out don't
paranoid hahaha sad should we kill him
or what I have I have acid my sights
what what he's standing just outside the
door he is yes he just put his torch
away yeah yeah yeah got him
ah yeah did he close the door though
yeah oh you surprised spawned in there
what I thought we were friends
oh my god a little bit I gotta stop
do you open got him you got him yes and
you're in he opened the door and I
blasted him did you get his stuff oh
yeah I'm getting his stuff from outside
oh my god we got hey there was actually
stuff in his furnace too oh my god oh
let's get out of here get her so quick
oh he's got leather animal fat towards
the moon yes run towards the moon
excellent idea
vague hey that's freaking awesome
yeah we're horrible people yeah okay uh
money towards the moon is actually gonna
get us back to the road it will yeah and
I think I think I'll just start the
episode moister creepy oh my god that
was fun
oh my god my hurts wait I totally get
that now you get that yeah I feel bad
but then again I don't vote I'm going up
the hill are you with me yes I'm running
currently up the hill I see you in the
distance in front of me okay so he
doesn't know where we are we're in in
the mountains yeah I'm so weird please
go necklace of me my viewers and he's
just like totally torn up about this why
did he open the door I have no idea you
know if he didn't open the door we would
have been I would have had my shotgun
trained on the door and you would have
start hatching again we were taunted him
like we're coming again yeah so I forget
exactly how to get to back to the place
from here
I just crested the hill I'm coming down
the hill now are you still behind me
yeah I think so stop where you are yes I
think I see you jumping over there um
make a left go up into the mountains yes
make a left go that way and then take a
right after this one and then just keep
following the edge of the mountain till
you generally get to it the start spot
for everyone watching it's not about
this way uh yeah going down there you're
not going up the mountain just going
around it yeah yeah you can go around it
okay uh we take a little bit right no
right great Hey
go over this rock here okay I didn't
take this way before but I should have
because I was stupid
apparently and then go in here yeah you
still follow me right with ya
uh I am the footsteps behind you yeah
good just so I don't get paranoid here
oh we did it mom we banded we are the
best bandits
we totally raped and pillaged that guy
he probably logged off cuz he's so sad
hmm hey celebratory fire well now I
actually feel better knowing that my
fort can't be breached by anything
besides explosives I'm gonna put wood in
here see so we can get just some light
yes so how many metal fragments do we
need for what the machine gun yeah oh
yes Oh for the silencer oh we need ah 8
times 15 which is oh god I can't do math
right now
well how many how many do you have I
have 160 that would probably not I have
34 I stole from him we should use those
on the silencer actually what we should
actually what I mean is I have 250 right
now oh and I think I have some in
storage hang on should I that I took
those out of storage should I craft
those into low quality mouths yes craft
them all into low quality metal and hand
them over to me coz I have the recipe
I'm gonna build something else how many
low quality is a 15 low quality metal
it's 8 to make a silencer but I have an
even better idea
well how many should I make then all of
them all of them alterna moly did you
I'm gonna put the rocks in the furnace
to get that going I have a workbench I'm
next to a workbench what do you want
from a game you gotta be even close crap
I think I just picked up your sleeping
bag what I didn't even know that was
possible
oh I'm sharing with you that's right
give it back there you go
do it just do do you think thank you
don't look turn around see what done
nope no dirt no that doesn't even make
sense
okay put all your rocks in whatever in
your I have 16 low-quality metal in one
where the furnace yeah put it in the
furnace
you're you're occupying it re I'm out of
it geez like we're back old roommates do
the stones go in there no stones don't
do anything stones are for like very low
basic stuff stones are for noobs yes
don't different news gotta be on our
level right here's here's your metal low
quality metal on the floor there go nuts
do I have enough oh how many more do you
need
oh I thought I got enough I need four
more to me I wanted to make a m4 I can
make two more nah we need four more okay
what we'll do is we'll just make a
silencer and we'll give it to you um
let's see you be better off with them
this daughter would be better off with I
might be better off in terms of ammo
with a pistol cuz I you you you uh kind
of unleashed the beast on him yeah well
he was that support also here's low
quality metal here for you okay alright
ah [ __ ] I don't have any pre upgraded p2
50s which are better than nine
millimeters in that they're more oh you
totally do have a pickaxe you lyin ass
mother oh yeah here I just didn't bring
it oh I'm coming online as mother humbo
I asked you before you left if we had
one oh here's a p250 it's not there's a
p250 over here is that what you're
looking for Lucy it's in the small stash
on the right ah that's a p250 but it
doesn't have enough upgrades I wanted
something with everything upgraded you
already have a flashlight on that so I'm
just gonna make you a silencer for that
one just uh be better with your ammo
awesome I do you have any more ammo can
we yes I can make more ammo okay oh [ __ ]
we don't have metal frame I think we
might have enough for some I have three
more metal fragments in here alright
putting a silencer on the ground like
right behind you okay
and I just stack that on my gun yeah
just throw it right on sweet Lina
pretty sweet I can actually make a
silencer for my shotgun it would be very
strange but I guess yeah silent shotgun
it makes sense everyone's dead aloof
yeah it's like when someone tries to
sneeze and doesn't let it out yeah oh
unlike Dane Cook's oh yeah zone air
here's this stuff for you would stuff as
sulfur and metal fragment oh I had a
flashlight right here I could have done
that [ __ ] I wish you could remove things
yeah yeah but de game's not good enough
for that
oh you can't unload things that's cool
yeah mmm
that's useful because I was just
thinking like now there are permanently
30 bullets in this gun oh there are not
yeah we how do you unload things right
click it and unload it's an option I
know that was a thing I I did never
think of right-clicking on stuff - whoa
just like right-clicking on furnace
Susan one nut and all that sort of jazz
I'm gonna do something for you I want
you to have a pistol that has a silenced
but because it's just it's just good to
have generally cuz pistols are pretty
powerful just being honest but see and I
already have a flashlight on it so you
can have a flashlight silence your
pistol got that ok boopity boop ok here
take that
that is your upgraded p250 so you want
your uh machine gun bag I just put it in
storage just in case you know we need to
later is it day out yes finally daya God
that was a long night
ah ok everybody watching we are back in
business for them do we want a murder
pillage do you want to try to collect
materials I have a little which one to
do it more fun having like dude the
pillaging was more fun for us a fact for
the viewers it was a lot of like I'm
gonna crouch go to the left just what
watch him and I got him hahaha this
tension about tension
gotta bring up the tension super
dramatic strings music over that I could
do this I could do that actually Tom
Clancy that Barry can you how I put I
put a silencer on my shotgun so we're
good good to go actually let me see how
this down watch actually wait tell me
how this down
cod
did you hear that was pretty pretty
quiet for a shotgun I'm surprised I've
never had a silent shotgun before but
yeah the ultimate hunting machine but
you want to go uh kill some dudes I
totally just got a bunch of ammo you
have a bunch of ammo and all your guns
in storage oh I do
I didn't know that I now have 43 bullets
instead of like 12 good and anymore
there's any got more guns that might be
loaded around Oh just shotgun guns I
guess now we should be good all right
let's go hunt some [ __ ] yeah uh uh
what that didn't come out right
sorry that sounds horrifying oh no hang
on wait no I I meant to say something
else but just ignore everyone ignore
that everyone rewind and delete that
never happened rewind and delete that
you know what I meant you think people
are doing you know what I said shut up
here-here's take some more nice chicken
I said what you meant you pigmen [ __ ]
you didn't mean wow that's a lot of
chicken we need more metal need this
should I bring a pickaxe just to see if
that's more efficient or yeah maybe I
don't know oh no I really don't know if
it's like better or worse I'll take one
too there's two pickaxes take that one
out of the other room and tell I'll take
this one you take okay okay geez going
to be so confrontational on everything
just okay I was just trying to be a dick
yeah yeah one are you so good at it
uh-huh boom
oh really start let's go got my pickaxe
let's do it all right just rule
minecraft right god no yes maybe I don't
I want to pickaxe everything oh no all
right what we're gonna do is we're gonna
go straight up over the mountain I'm
gonna show you this guy's based I hope
he's not home cuz we might be in trouble
if he is but I'm just gonna have tilings
pistols well I am running very slowly up
the mountain go cross zigzag uh
serpentine
yes serpentine and also I'm gonna do the
shotgun you do the pistol so you talk to
the people
and then I'll hug him in the back how do
we get up here okay got everyone
watching I've gotten a taste for blood
and now it'll never be satiated yeah
yeah I'll get up here I gotta be Reiser
before uh how do I get up there I don't
know just keep trying you'll get up here
eventually
there's his power you know that might
actually be the admins place I wouldn't
be surprised you up here Bob no how did
you jump over there I don't know how did
you jump over where Vicki pay up
currently stuck in a hole
let's get bad are you I am trying Bob we
are the worst bandits ever oh I made it
up okay there you come along little
duckling Robo clear okay I see that oh
wow yeah I know right well yeah he's
built like one hell of a place is really
fine can we like climb is Tower and
stuff it's Oh actually no it's like
almost like unbreakable because it's uh
it's like based so that the foundation
is really high and like you he's only
got one open bottom layer but the thing
about the bottom layer is that it like
it's got a metal door that leads to the
rest of the area and I don't know how to
get up higher cuz he's got these wooden
barricades set up yeah wow I don't even
know how tough up there but yeah what
the heck and he's got metal doors
blocking the way up I know the starter
kid on this server used to be uh uh you
get a free metal door but they stopped
doing that yeah geez kind of overpowered
but yeah so that's that man that's like
an impenetrable fortress of Awesome I
know this is pretty clue also with this
view over here overlooking this valley
is good to go and you can spot anyone
walking from like miles away to let
you'll find someone Bob I went to get on
did you see where I went no where'd you
go damn it Bob where are you oh come on
we're going to break my leg as I run
down and only be a temporary break
band-aids will fix me right up certainly
will it take
Obed but it'll get it go wow I this is
this is intense
what the crap what oh yeah ha ha just
like flying on the side of a mountain
yeah going down a mountain is very
equitable oh no that was nothing
cloud I saw a person who's a wooden
stick ever oh yeah I see that it does
look like a person I used to have a base
tucked in these mountains until someone
found me and killed me the douches but
now we are now we are the deuces indeed
lots of reason we are way the douches
yeah I guess we could be normal and
actually get normal resources like guys
whatever that we earned with the sled of
the [ __ ] ha ha ha then we earned one off
our brow is that what you're trying to
say whatever ha ha ha someone dropped
fan art of the [ __ ] on our brow yes no
actually no that's bad don't do that
never mind what on our brow that's not
and this pickaxe is awesome
is it yeah I collect like 16 at a time
oh damn Oh God in heaven I got it there
we go
we don't need that well I don't need
that you can harvest it if you want I've
long since moved past cloth blooded
chicken breasts do you see anyone oh no
nope nope nope you got quieter all of a
sudden do you move away from Mike no no
oh you're just talking quieter I I do
change the volume level of my voice on
occasion I don't I'm always loud no
matter what huh that's surprisingly true
yeah I ever tell you about the time I
was recording for Polaris and um hey
Mark what found a structure yeah I see
it
I'm not going towards it where are you I
am straight out of the door straight
away from the door I'm moving to the
left are you are you on the right side
of it yeah kinda I'm just charging it
what are you doing Oh baby that's gonna
crouch and
Wow this is their one serious fortress
how do you build multi-levels like this
you just keep building up you can build
wooden stairs this is amazing it's cuz
their case all around how do you even
get in ha ha ha the gates yeah Wow is
impressive can you like force your way
over wooden barricades and just eat the
damage or is that not polish I don't
think so I don't think it would be wise
to try oh let's stay away from there
because whoever's doing that one is me
serious business Cod thing we should try
to build something like that I don't
weep my dinky little does a lot of good
and stuff yeah we got to collect
resources and steal some wooden parts Oh
Shack
where a shadow shack a real Shack oh
it's dead the dead jack terminates dead
shacks are we gonna stay out in the
plains and look for for resources still
there Gatsby all legitimate about it oh
it's still boring I want to shoot
someone in the face could shoot me in
the face you don't don't don't that I
don't know don't point that at me I'll
point this at you there's a wolf I don't
want to shoot hell for no face could
shoot a wolf in the face how is that not
fun it's not a person I do sound like a
psychopath playing these games don't it
kind uh uh uh what oh well whatever
oh come on girl that's a little faster
uh-uh no ok no all right what we'll do
is we'll cut the episode here and then
we'll start up the next episode as soon
as we find some more peace ok ok ok so
thank you all stood for what oh what Oh
what
go on go ahead thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation or videos
that I've done thank you Bob for bigger
and as always we'll see you even in
Hey hey guys did someone just say that
the devil is in the ballroom talking to
miss Carroll
there was somebody else in the room